let's think about how hydrogen bromide
might react with this thing right here
and let's think about what this would be
called we have one two three four five
carbons it has a double bond right here
if we start numbering at this end
because that's where the double bond is
then this would be pent this is pent the
double bond starts at the number one
carbon pent 1 and it's obviously an
alkene it has a double bond so it's pent
1 in sometimes this is called 1-pentene
1-pentene either way so let's think
about how these two characters might
react with each other in some type of
solvent usually when a solvents not
specified it's usually water or alcohol
if this was water then this would
actually be we would have a solution of
hydrobromic acid but let's not worry
about that right now let's just worry
about how these two these two characters
might react with each other now the
first thing we might look at is this
hydrogen bromide right there and as you
get more experience there you'll say
well you know bromine is much more
electronegative than hydrogen it likes
to hog electrons much more and if that's
if that's a completely foreign concept
to you I'll do a little bit of a review
this is a periodic table
electronegativity increases from the
bottom left to the top right of the
periodic table
electro electronegativity and they
electronegativity and really that's just
a fancy way of saying how much does an
atom like to hog electrons so for
example fluorine loves to hog electrons
and calcium doesn't like the hog
electrons so much so when if we think
about hydrogen bromide hydrogen's way up
here on the left side of the periodic
table bro means all the way to the right
bromine is much more electronegative so
in this situation since bromine is more
electronegative it will hog the
electrons in this bond and since it's
hogging the electrons in this bond
you'll have a partial negative charge on
the bromine end you'll have a partial
negative charge on the bromine end and
you'll have a partial positive charge on
the hydrogen end and whenever you do
these reactions actually is useful to
draw all of the valence electrons so
bromine right here bromine right here it
has an atomic number of 30
five which means it has 35 electrons in
its neutral state and we don't have any
charge here so it's in a neutral state
but you can look at its group it's in
group number seven if you count from
here one two three four five six seven
or it has seven valence electrons so let
me draw that seven electrons in its
outermost shell
let me draw them right here so one two
three four five six and then the seventh
is in the bond with the hydrogen
hydrogen obviously has one electron
hydrogen has one electron it's right
there so these two guys are bonding with
each other and they both allow each
other to pretend that they're part of a
pair and that's what gives it a lower
energy level or makes a little more
stable that's why the bond forms in the
first place but anyway let's think about
what might happen here this guy is
really electronegative so maybe he wants
to hog this maybe he wants to take this
electron away this green this green
hydrogen electron maybe that happens
maybe that happens but that can't look
let me just draw it out so maybe that
happens so he takes that electron that
green electron where it's just getting
closer and closer if there's only some
other place that this hydrogen could get
an electron from then this guy could
just go to the bromine which is what
bromine really wants to happen because
it's so electronegative so where can the
hydrogen get an electron to replace the
one that it's about to lose well we have
a double bond here and maybe one of
these carbons lose an electron and in
future videos we'll talk more which one
is more likely to give up the electron
at this stage of the reaction but just
for simplicity let's say let's assume
let's assume that this carbon right here
this carbon right here gives up an
electron where its valence electrons and
just as a bit of review here's carbon on
the periodic table it has 6 it has 6
protons and 6 electrons in its stable
state to are sitting in its first shell
and then the other for its valence
electrons and you could see that it's in
group 4 right 1 2 3 4 we could ignore
these for now and usually you're not
going to be dealing with well we'll
ignore those for now it has 4 valence
electrons most of what you're going to
deal with you just have to count the
group numbers like this we won't worry
too much about all of the metals and all
right now now it's four valence
electrons and you see it right here it
has one two three four valence electrons
it has two and it's one shell so it
actually has six but you only draw the
four out there so what we're saying is
this green electron can go to the
bromine as long as he can take as long
as the hydrogen can take an electron
maybe from this carbon right here so
let's draw that so this this electron
right here is going to go to the
hydrogen and when that electron goes to
the hydrogen simultaneously that will
allow this electron to go to bromine
obviously they won't be this far when it
happens there would be some type of
collision that would have to occur in
just the right way with you know just
the right level of energy for this to
occur maybe the hydrogen is getting
really close to this part right at the
right moment when this electron is being
sucked away from the bromine so this has
a partial positive charge attracted the
electron that electron goes over there
it won't always happen but this is a
potential reaction mechanism but this
whole step happens at once this electron
goes from this character to the hydrogen
at the same time as hydrogen loses its
electron to the to the bromine so what's
the what's the what's going to happen
right after this step what's going to
happen right after this step so right
after that happens what will everything
look like well we'll have the bromine
will have gained the electron so it's
now a bromide ion so let me draw it like
this so it had its original seven
valence electrons 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 and now
it just stole an electron from the
hydrogen it was able to swipe an
electron off the hydrogen that's the
electron it swiped off the hydrogen and
now what will this thing that was
1-pentene or pen 20 what will this look
like now let me draw it so we have a
carbon and a hydrogen and a hydrogen and
then you have a carbon and then a
hydrogen and then you have the rest of
the chain right over here you have the
rest of the chain right over here but
this double bond was broken this carbon
lost an electron went to the hydrogen so
this double this bond right here now
forms between this carbon and that
hydrogen so let me draw that bond so
this bond actually
draw it that you have this electron
right there that electron will now be
with the hydrogen's let me draw the
electron and now we have that orange
hydrogen I'll try to keep the colors
consistent so that we know where things
came from and then we have this bond now
to the hydrogen now this carbon now only
has three valence electrons one two
three it has to sitting in its first
shell so it actually has a total of five
electrons has six protons so as a
positive charge this carbon right here
has a positive charge and another way to
think about it is it was completely
neutral and then it lost an electron so
now we'll have a positive charge right
over there so this is what we are left
after that step of the reaction now as
you can imagine oh and of course we
can't forget bromine over here was
neutral it had seven valence electrons
and that's when bromine is neutral but
now has eight so now this will have a
negative charge this will have a
negative charge this will have a
negative charge because it gained an
electron and in general your total
charge over here our total charge is
zero so our total charge should still be
zero we have a negative and we have a
positive they would cancel out so our
total charge is still zero so what's
likely to happen for the next step of
our reaction well we have this positive
thing here maybe you know bromine just
bumped just the right way to into this
to let go of this guy and steals
electron but now you have this guy whose
negative and this guy who's positive
maybe they'll be attracted to each other
maybe they'll just bump into each other
at the exact right way and if they bump
in the exact right way maybe this guy
can swap swipe the electron from the
from the bromide ion from this negative
ion right here and you might say hey it
isn't bromine more electronegative than
carbon well it might be but this guy is
electron rich it's not just a regular
bromine atom this is this is a this is a
bromine plus an extra electron so he's
already hugged an electron so he's
electron rich so in this situation he's
negative he's positive he's he can give
this guy an electron so they bump in
just the right way this electron this
electron can be swiped by this carbon
right over here by that carbon right
over here and this positive carbon just
to give you
terminology and we'll go go over it in
more detail in future videos it's
actually called a carbo-cation it's a
positive ion of carbon that's where the
word comes from but anyway if this
electron gets swiped by this car but
it'll then form a bond because remember
this was the electron that was
originally in a bond in a bond with this
hydrogen it's still going to be you
could imagine pair it up with this other
purple or magenta electron right over
there so if that happens then we're
going to be left with so the next step
is going to be so on this end of the
molecule we have C carbon hydrogen
hydrogen then we have this orange
hydrogen that we stole from the hydrogen
bromide
then we have then we have this carbon
right here it has a hydrogen they have
the rest of the chain ch2 ch2 ch3 and
now since this guy stole an electron it
will bond will form with the bromine so
now let me draw it let me draw it so
he's going to steal this let me draw it
this way so a bond will form he's
stealing this electron so now this
electron is with this carbon so I can do
it as one end of the bond the other end
of the bond will be that magenta
electron right there on the bromine and
now the bromine lost an electron so it's
neutral it once again has 1 2 3 4 5 6 7
valence electrons carbon is now neutral
because it gained an electron it once
again has 1 2 3 4 electron so now
everyone is happy again so we in this
video we're able to get a mechanism and
we can talk in the future about how
likely it is to happen how quickly it
might happen we were able to start with
hydrogen bromide and 1-pentene or pent
1e and get to this thing and just by
pushing around electrons and just
thinking about what is likely to happen
based on what's electronegative and what
might be able to gain or lose an
electron in just a bit of a review what
is this thing right here this might be
let's see this is 1 2 3 4 5 carbon steel
so it's going to be a pent it's now it's
now an alkane no double bond so it's
pentane and it has one group on it so
we'll start numbering close to the group
so 1 2 it's 2
bromo pentane to bromo pentane so we
were able to figure out a reaction
mechanism to get us from hydrogen
bromide and 1-pentene to to bromo
pentane